how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have our favorite thing
Avengers end game leaks
obviously with Avengers in game Marvel
is being as secretive as they possibly
can I mentioned in a video yesterday
that the Russo brothers said that we
actually really have no idea what
Avengers in game is really going to be
about so we'll take any type of leaks
that we can possibly get and it appears
that some people saw a scene from
Avengers in game went to the Internet
and leaked it as fast as they possibly
could now this obviously happens it
happened for Avengers infinity war as
well people are working on the set or
work on editing the film and they see
the movie and they go online and they
leaked it they usually do this on reddit
or through another person because
they've usually signed a contract that
says they won't share anything that
they've seen so they do it this way
anonymously so they won't get fired so
needless to say spoiler warning if this
ends up being true and is in Avengers in
game there will obviously be spoilers in
this video but of course normal
disclaimer this may not end up being
true there's a lot of leaks out there
some end up being true some end up not
being true for Avengers infinity war we
actually got a lot of leaks that ended
up being for the most part true but take
this with a grain of salt also only two
days left in my Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway I am picking a new winner on
February 1st so if you would like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero okay so this scene takes place
on what this person describes as what he
believes to be a part of Xander and just
so everybody knows this is not leaked
footage from a trailer it's not the
opening scene it's just a scene in
Avengers endgame so in this scene Thanos
has arrived on Xander with the Black
Order and his army he does not have the
Infinity Gauntlet on instead he has his
armor and his double bladed sword
although Thanos does not have any of the
Infinity stones yet the Avengers are
still losing to him the black order and
his army the xandarians are getting
defeated by the Chitauri and the
outriders and the avengers are getting
defeated by Thanos and his Black Order
Captain America and Iron Man regroup and
Steve tells Tony that they're not going
to win this battle Tony says what do you
pose we do because we're out of time and
down to the wire Captain America replies
we should cut the wire right as Steve
says this to Tony Vanna shows up right
in front of them
iron man's helmet forms around his head
and Captain America lifts up his shield
but then we see Captain Marvel fly-in
and punched Thanos in the face with an
energy blast which sends him flying
Captain Marvel then gives Tony a metal
case that contains the power stone in it
Tony immediately gives it to war machine
and Rhodey puts the case into a huge
device the end of the scene is a huge
white blast that eventually takes up all
of the screen and ends the scene and
that's it for this leaked description of
the scene so there are a few things from
this leaked description that I really
like and that add up really well the
first is that the Avengers will go back
in time or to an alternate reality to
Xander this makes sense because Xander
is where Thanos gets the first infinity
stone the Power Stone and it makes sense
that the Avengers would try to stop
daños before he got any of the Infinity
stones and the Power Stone is the one
stone that we never saw Thanos get in
Avengers infinity war we never saw the
sand are seen at all we just heard Thor
tell the guardians of the galaxy that
Thanos decimated Xander to get the Power
Stone in this scene it still sounds like
Thanos pretty much decimates and are but
the Avengers and Captain Marvel helped
defeat Thanos and saves and are so maybe
they were just saving the scene for
avengers endgame the next thing I really
like is when Captain America is talking
to Iron Man and they talk about cutting
the wire this is a reference to the
first Avengers film you're not the guy
to make the sacrifice play to lay down
on a wire or let the other guy crawl
over you I think I would just cut the
wire
always weigh out the first Avengers film
is obviously where Toni and Steve's
friendship developed and started and
Avengers endgame is supposed to wrap up
the story arc from the first 10 years so
since this is supposed to be the end
it's called a reference back to the
beginning and then at the end where
Captain Marvel comes in punches Thanos
in the face and then gives Tony Stark of
the Power Stone it makes perfect sense
that Captain Marvel would be the one to
retrieve the Power Stone she's probably
the only one strong enough to wield it
if it almost killed star-lord when he
was still half celestial it'll kill any
of the Avengers so she goes and gets the
Power Stone puts it in some sort of case
probably like the orb that star-lord
kept it in she gives it to Tony Tony
gives it to Rhodey
and Rohde puts it in a machine I'm gonna
guess that this is the proton cannon
that we've all been speculating about
for such a long time now it powers the
proton cannon and Rhodey lets it loose
and that's the end of the scene to me
this sounds really awesome and sounds
like something that could definitely
play out in Avengers endgame but again
like I said take this with a grain of
salt there are a ton of leaks that come
out and some are true and some are not
true either way they're really fun to
talk about and some do end up being true
and again in Avengers infinity war there
were a few leaks that came out that
ended up being true so you never know
but let me know what you all think about
this would you be excited to see this
scene play out in Avengers in game let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below and again another reminder be
sure to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway and stay up to date on
everything related to Avengers endgame
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you